you wrote
the book american cosmic ufos religion
technology what was the goal of writing
this book
what uh maybe we'll mention it we have
already mentioned it
many times but in this little
space of a conversation can you say
maybe what is the key insight that you
found that lingers with you to this day
from the process the long process of
uh putting this book together sure just
like with my book on purgatory
um i went into the research thinking
that it would be something
that it was entirely not it ended up
being something completely different
and i think that's good i think that
people who do research
need to are very excited actually when
their research surprises them
so i was happily surprised by my
purgatory book
to learn that it was a place you know
and and so
um i went into
american cosmic being a non-believer
in ufos entirely and i came out
being agnostic okay
kind of believer
yeah so agnostic sort of uh
open to the mysteries of the world yes
and
i didn't think that first of all i knew
that the
government was it was part
of the situation i just didn't know how
much
and so i learned that quickly and
acclimated to it
um accepted it and
noted that indeed
horatio the world
is much more mysterious than we think
it is it's more mystery there are more
mysteries in
this life than your philosophy provides
for
so as a sense american cosmic is about
the mysteries of the modern life as
encapsulated by this
the the realm of technology in the realm
of alien intelligences
yes i think that um i think that
i mean i'd have to go off record as a
professor and talk personally
as a person i do think that um
there are mysteries of which
we have an inkling and if it's something
as powerful as
non-human intelligence whether or not
it's from another
planet extraterrestrial or it happens to
be from
like another dimension or something else
i think that
this is going to get the attention of
institutions of power and indeed i think
that's what has happened
and although probably
he people have had interactions with
these things
it appears to me historically for
a long time as long as humans have
existed i would imagine
that indeed
this is something that's quite powerful
and could change the
belief structures of our entire
societies our civilization basically so
it's the same way that you're
talking the belief structures were
strongly affected by religious beliefs
throughout history in the same way this
has the potential
uh it it uh serves as um
a source of concern for the powerful
because
it can have very significant effects on
the populace
yes
you